es el primer ex presidente en ser
acusado en la historia de Estados Unidos
qué representa esto para el país
un momento importante
que va a poner a prueba la independencia
judicial y comienza un proceso intenso
una lucha entre la defensa del
presidente Trump y los fiscales en Nueva
York todavía no tenemos acceso a la
acusación ese documento está sellado ese
pliego acusatorio mantiene sellado vamos
a tener conocimiento de de los cargos
específicos la semana que viene y lo que
se está negociando en este momento lo
que se está organizando coordinando es
la llegada de Trump a Nueva York se
tiene que entregar en el tribunal
comparecer ante un magistrado
tiene que ser fichado tiene que ser sus
huellas dactilares tomadas el proceso de
de leerle las acusaciones de que haga
sus alegaciones ya sea de culpabilidad o
de no culpabilidad Y entonces comienza
el proceso que desemboca un juicio que
no debe tomar posiblemente
más de de una serie de meses etcétera y
en el que se podría estar exponiendo a
una pena de prisión si se le encuentra
culpable Más allá de dudas razonables de
la comisión de delito grave
para hacer una aclaración cuando usted
habla de que va a ser entregado porque
hay muchas especulaciones al respecto es
que va a ser detenido o cuál es el
proceso bueno
el ante la fiscalía él Allí se le va a
tomar
las huellas dactilares se le va a
ingresar su información en el sistema se
presenta ante un magistrado ante un juez
que le lee esas acusaciones y él allí
hace su alegación de culpabilidad o no
culpabilidad
él no se le va a él no se le va a meter
en prisión la semana que viene ni
tampoco se le impondrá una fianza con
toda posibilidad se le acuse y se deje
que se regrese a su casa no habrán
algunas condiciones y demás pero
recordemos de un expresidente le asiste
una presunción de inocencia él tiene
protección del servicio secreto verdad
Durante este proceso y lo va a seguir
teniendo es un acusado criminal sujeto
a las directrices del tribunal esperó él
tiene el derecho de ver ese caso en
corte y de defenderse no hay una
presunción de inocencia y la fiscalía es
el que tiene el peso de la prueba aquí
claro ahora conociendo el proceso hasta
ahora es un solo una acusación pero Qué
posibilidades hay de que se le declare
culpable eventualmente y que y de que
haya una condena en su contra por
ejemplo
Eso depende de primero Cuál es la prueba
que tiene la fiscalía Cuáles son los
cargos que la fiscalía está presentando
que prueba tiene y si logra convencer de
forma unánime a ese Jurado de hombres y
mujeres que son los que van a decidir
aquilatar esa prueba y en el análisis
final decidir si Trump es culpable o
Inocente de lo que se le acusa señor Cox
Y ahora qué impacto va a tener esta
decisión judicial en su candidatura a la
casa blanca muy brevemente por favor
bueno es posible que el partido
republicano se quiera alejar de alguien
que está acusado de delito grave la
Constitución Americana no le pone trabas
verdad la Constitución no establece unas
limitaciones Más allá de de edad y
ciudadanía y residencia verdad depende
el partido republicano debería de
alejarse de una figura como esa